tuxedos in hand mike and his mates are
heading from swansea to london for a
work party
they'll get to the event okay but it's
coming home that's the problem so you're
going to try and get back to the swansea
i mean there's no trains back to swansea
tomorrow no so our hope is to possibly
get back to cardiff if we can't get back
to cardiff then it unfortunately is
either a flight or somebody's going to
have to take the bullet they'll bite the
bullet even and
drive back and rent the car
swansea station sees more than two
million passengers every year but during
this strike not a single train will come
in or out
and it's not just passengers affected
firearm has run cafe break opposite the
station for the last four years no
trains means takings will be down
example uh saturday it was a concert in
cardiff
and loads of people coming to the
takeaway come and take and take a while
and go
it was good i mean but there's no train
no customers
it's going to affect me and i mean
i'm in a negative feeling
but what can i do
millions will be caught up in travel
chaos this week
with wales one of the most impacted
parts of the country
cardiff will be the end of the line
during this strike nothing will run west
of here and there'll be no trains at all
in mid and north wales
but as the final rush to get home gets
underway many commuters say changes to
the way they work mean the strike has
less impact we're able to work from home
so we're hybrid working anyways we just
said to our people
and just work from home for the week so
it's fine
how badly are the strikes impacting you
i'm just going to work from home i'm
going to avoid traveling this week just
because
i rely on a train to travel back and
forth so i'm just going from home work
at home eighty percent of the time now
um probably will continue to do so
not too worried about strike
no lucky
hybrid working or not this is the
biggest strike in 30 years and there is
no denying there'll be significant
impact as our railways grind to a halt
dan white is sky news in cardiff